hello
i am alice kaplan director of the
whitney humanities center
welcome to the spring 2021 fincey
cantini lecture
before megan o'rourke introduces our
distinguished speaker aaron diaz
i'd like to say a few words about the
history and the tradition behind today's
event
the fincey contini lectureship was
endowed in 1990
by the honorable guido calabresi judge
of the u.s court of appeals for the
second circuit
and former dean of the yale law school
it was also endowed by his brother the
late dr paul
calabrese this lecture honors their
mother
bianca maria fincicontini carabrezi
she and her husband massimo early
activists in the resistance to italian
fascism
fled italy in 1939 after the passage of
the first
infamous racial laws they settled in new
haven to start anew
he as a physician she as a literary
scholar
bianca maria vinci contini earned her
phd in french at yale
in 1949 with a dissertation on the
scholarly
influences on ernest linold's secular
upbringing her subject leno
is one of the most fascinating writers
of the 19th century
a free thinker and brilliant analyst of
nationalism
and of christianity who believed in
racial hierarchies but nonetheless
counted among his enemies the most
vicious anti-semites in france
lore has it that professor ollie pale
the director of bianca finzicontini's
thesis
wanted to appoint her to the faculty at
yale but the 1949 yale corporation
refused
there would be no tenured woman on the
faculty at yale for another full
decade bianca maria vincy cantini went
on to become
professor of french and italian at
connecticut college
then chair of the department of italian
at albertus magnus college
her last published volume was also
written in french like her dissertation
and it was on
renault's relations with one of the
founders of classic
philology she died in 1982
at the age of 80. i'd like to take this
opportunity
to thank judge calabrese and his family
for their generosity
and for giving us the privilege of
remembering our distinguished alumna
bianca maria fincicontini
the fincey contini lecture sponsors a
distinguished speaker in the field of
comparative literature
broadly defined over the years the
whitney has welcomed
translators editors theorists and
practitioners of literature
the inaugural lecture in the series was
delivered in 1991
by the great italian semiotician umberto
ecco
this year for the first time the whitney
humanities center
is joining with the yale review as
co-sponsors of the fincey cantini
lecture
it's my great pleasure now to introduce
the editor of the yale review megan
o'rourke
who took over the editorship of the yell
review in early 2020
as the magazine was celebrating its
200th
anniversary a graduate of yale
megan is an accomplished poet and
essayist
a former editor at the new yorker the
paris review and slate
she's the author of the best-selling
memoir the long goodbye
and three poetry collections she's
published essays on the love poems of
thomas hardy
on guantanamo on john ashbury
and on the early history of young adult
detective fiction
she has spent this pandemic year
finishing her next book of nonfiction
on appropriately enough illness
she's the recipient of many literary
awards including a guggenheim alanna
fellowship
and two pushcart prizes so megan i'm
passing the floor or the square
to you to introduce hernan diaz
thank you i'm sorry i i clicked on too
early but all the nicer to share the
screen
with you alice good afternoon everyone
i am extremely pleased to welcome hernan
diaz to give the finsi contini lecture
today
um at the whitney humanities center and
i want to thank alice kaplan and the
center for inviting the yale review to
be a co-sponsor
of this event we're very excited to say
that we'll be publishing
um hernan's lecture in print
in our summer issue which i'll remind
you of at the end so
we hope you'll subscribe or get a copy
okay hernan diaz is the author of a
study of jorge luis borges the argentine
essayist and poet
titled borges between history and
eternity
as well as the brilliant novel in the
distance a finalist for the 2018
pulitzer prize and the
penn faulkner award among many other
citations that year
in this novel diaz turns the conventions
of the american western on their head
subverting expectations and writing a
work of fiction that in the end becomes
a profound
meditation on storytelling on both the
intimate and
national scale while westerns are
typically set
after the civil war this one is set
before it and its hero is a recent
immigrant from sweden
hawk hawcon soderstrom who doesn't speak
english for much of the novel as he
journeys
journeys across america in search of his
lost older brother
a journey that takes him eastward toward
new york city
rather than westward away from it in an
interview diaz referred to his novel as
a quote
western without cowboys quote and noted
that
i thought it was important to quite
literally alienate the genre
in order to question the ossified
political assumptions
at its core end quote the subverted
western frame of in the distance
asks us to think about what and who has
been counted as american in a history
that has whitewashed its own violence
and holds in productive tension for the
reader
ideas of foreignness and ideas of
connection
as when hawk on adrift in a new world
searching for connection meets a
scientist who teaches him
english and introduces him to the notion
that the bond between all living things
is the quote true religion most of all
though this becomes a discerning astute
frame
to for thinking about why we tell
stories at all
and how they comfort us uh over the
course of the novel diaz reflects on
this question
very profoundly very movingly very um
uh luminously and at one point we meet
hawk on
reflecting on the fact that his brother
whom he's missing that his stories quote
endow the world with meaning
and that through these stories life was
contained becoming something that could
be examined
and understood in today's talk diaz
examines the art of fiction in order to
help us better understand
how it offers us truths we cannot find
elsewhere
and how reading rather than research
might best help the writer
of fiction achieve the goals of building
a persuasive
new reality diaz
serves as an associate director of the
hispanic institute at columbia
university
born in argentina he was raised in
sweden studied
in london and new york and now lives in
brooklyn with his wife and daughter
i very much recommend that you you read
his novel it's
one of my favorite books of the last
years um
tonight he's going to speak to us about
fiction and
about for about 40 minutes and then
we'll take questions
from the audience and for me for about
10. to ask a question
and i'll remind you of this at the end
we ask that you please use the q
and a feature at the bottom of the
screen
in the meantime please join me in giving
a very warm welcome to hernan diaz thank
you so much
hi hi megan um thank you for uh
your extremely generous uh introduction
uh thank you also alice kaplan diane
brown
the whitney humanities center and
everyone at the yale review for this
wonderful invitation
and thank you uh all for uh being here
in one way or another uh it's uh
an overwhelming honor to be delivering
uh the fincey contini
lecture and um truly humbling to see so
many of
my heroes in the um archives
excuse me alice just mentioned umberto
eco but stay tuned today of uh
charles rosen uh ws merwin
are in there and it's uh it's a it's
really
an immense honor um uh i would also like
to thank my
friends paul stacy and elisa rodriguez
ferguson for the many conversations i
had with them as i
as i wrote this text and um
i should also say that megan's
invitation arrived as i was starting to
work with
my editor on a novel i have just
finished
this book this new book is very much
about the notion
of fiction what what does fiction mean
how do stories
shape our perception of reality how can
fiction
alter and even constitute reality
i thought it would be productive to
present these questions
in an essayistic form after having
written the novel
uh the essay has nothing to do with the
novel uh um
plot-wise of course because as you'll
hear in a moment
this is a concern i've had for many
years now what
does fiction say about the world
and the many ways in which we experience
it and
moreover how does fiction fit
in the world so this talk
will be as megan said uh 40 minutes and
it's divided into
uh five uh sections uh the title
is of course upon a loving pun on
henry james's essay the art of fiction
which i'll reference in a moment
the heart of fiction fiction writers
are a famously neurotic bunch
haunted by self-doubt from time to time
this unease spreads and swells into a
general state of disquiet and even
shock as if fiction itself suddenly
realized to its dismay
that it's just fiction why dwell
on made-up stories why make them up
in the first place one response
has often been to present fiction as
something useful
a fabrication certainly but one redeemed
by serving a purpose
say religious instruction moral
edification
political enlightenment or even
self-discovery
the opposite response claiming that
stories serve
no purpose at all is just as common
fiction is an invention yes but it's
completely harmless
irrelevant play a pastime detached from
real life
not to be taken seriously
the latest symptom of fiction's tendency
towards self-doubt
is a more or less pervasive referential
fetish as if a strict adherence to
verifiable facts
could dissipate this anxiety
i'd be unable to say when this first
started but
literature's fixation with accuracy
seems to be
a relatively new phenomenon i wonder for
instance
when fiction started to be fact checked
this impulse overlaps with the thought
that literature ought to be
researched an eloquent example of the
referential fetish
yet the notion of research implies
arriving at verifiable results through
scientific protocols and methods
that don't translate all that well into
the realm
of fiction there is actually a much
better word for this process in
literature
reading differentiating between these
two terms
is not a mere quibble the free
associations
the haphazard hermeneutics and perhaps
above all
the emotional dimension of reading
have nothing to do with research i would
even claim that what makes reading
so compelling and productive is
precisely
its lack of method and yet
the desire to get it right which i think
tends to go well beyond the reasonable
desire of saving oneself
from the occasional embarrassment of
getting it wrong
often prevails i see this happen to
fellow writers
i see it happen to me
another manifestation of the referential
fetish
is the increasingly strong link between
fiction and confession or witnessing
consider auto fiction and other
literatures of the self
that have gained so much prominence over
the last
few years here that mysterious maxim
according to which one should write
about what one knows
is taken to solipsistic extremes
the testimonial nature of these books is
not i believe
unrelated to the general sense of
anxiety
around the place of truth in fiction and
provides
a hedge against the demands of accuracy
and research
what is experienced witnessed or
remembered
need not be corroborated by other means
put differently a perceived lack of
objectivity
is offset by a surplus of subjectivity
the literature of the self offers the
promise of
immediacy and presents the first person
or its surrogate as the guarantor of
truth
i was there i did it i remember
it eating madeleine however
has never turned anyone into prused
even if there are many texts in this
auto-fictional vein that i admire
i must ultimately side with mary
mccarthy who
despite often smudging the boundaries
between fiction and autobiography
in her own work declared in the company
she keeps
with a brilliant pun that quote the home
address of the self
is not to be found in the book
yet it seems that auto fiction's promise
of closeness
and veracity has something to do with
the current prominence
of these kinds of texts
the referential fetish then seems to be
an
overcompensation for the uneasy
relationship
between fiction and truth this current
obsession
is not unrelated to the alarming turn
public discourse started taking some
four years ago
we all know what happened incontestable
facts
scientific reports election results and
even
daily events verifiable through our
senses
were exiled from the realm of truth
meanwhile the most outlandish narratives
were presented
as irrefutable reality
i don't intend uh to discuss here the
damage
this has done to a number of
institutions and how
it has eroded public trust in them
this has been the object of abundant
coverage elsewhere
my concern rather is what it has done
to fiction increasingly
over the past few years i've heard and
read a growing number of people say
they have lost interest in fiction
reality had become so daunting and the
proliferation of lies is so overwhelming
that these people had neither the time
nor the desire
to turn to novels and stories
the assumption here is that in addition
to being trivial make-believe
and a waste of time a classic perennial
objection
fiction is a betrayal of truth
that it's just a fake but
the opposite of truth is not fiction
but falsehood and not all
fictions are false
section two a pack of lies
truth is not a tenant we immediately
expect to reside in fiction
indeed we have grown used to
understanding the two categories in
opposition to each other fiction
may seem to be true it may emulate
truth and many believe this to be
fiction's greatest imperative
but it is often defined as an imaginary
construct
that in the end has little to do with
the pursuit of truth
what is expected of made up worlds is
that they
adequately mimic the real one and
short of that that these inventions be
internally consistent
disciplines with an overt claim to truth
which include fields as disparate as the
hard sciences
the law journalism have always taken
good care
to distance themselves from fiction a
word
they only deploy as an insult
yet i don't believe the relationship
between truth and fiction to be one of
rivalry or mutual exclusion
i am convinced that truth resides
in some way at the heart of fiction
in her author's notes sorry in her
author's note
to the left hand of darkness a science
fiction novel set
on the remote planet of geffen ursula le
guin
writes and i quote
fiction writers at least in their braver
moments
do desire the truth to know it
speak it serve it but
they go about it in a peculiar and
devious way
which consists in inventing persons
places and events which never did and
never will exist or occur
and telling about these fictions in
detail and at length
and with a great deal of emotion and
then
when they are done writing down this
pack of lies they say
there that's the truth
but what sort of truth
is this excuse me that was the end of
quote
but what sort of truth is this
i don't think it depends on how
accurately a certain historical period
is rendered in a novel how precisely a
city is mapped out in its pages
or how life-like its characters may be
after all the left hand of darkness
takes place in the future
in a world light years away from ours
nor do i think truth in this context
refers to
how successfully the story is how
successful the story is
at convincing readers to suspend their
disbelief
no matter how outlandish the plot or the
setting happens to be
we call such success very similitude
which means quite literally
resemblance to truth but le guin
draws a distinction between the devious
way
in which fiction proceeds by making
things up in detail
and the final result this believable
lifelike very similar pack of lies
aspires somewhat paradoxically to truth
itself not just its likeness
in short truth here has little to do
with a correspondence to referential
reality
how closely a story resembles life
how much it adheres to empirical facts
or how accurately it may capture a
historical period
is not the point nor are we considering
the epistemological dimension of fiction
or whether it should be treated as a
collection of falsifiable
statements the psychological side of
this issue
how faithfully the words on the page may
mirror the author's intention
is equally irrelevant here
lastly the plausibility of the story
is also unimportant just because
a realist novel takes place in britain
during the industrial revolution does
not mean
it has a higher truth value than a
science fiction story set on an
imaginary planet
in the distant future what i think
le guin is referring to then and what i
would like to discuss
here fully aware of how vague this may
sound
is how fiction rather than presenting us
with
truthful content shows us
how we experience truth
section three experience
perhaps fiction aspires to truth not by
capturing the world but by presenting
the many ways
in which we capture the world through
experience
the question that follows is of course
what
does experience mean and i have two
definitions by two
fiction writers
in the art of fiction 1884
henry james writes quote
experience is never limited and it is
never complete it is an immense
sensibility a kind of huge spider web
of the finest silicon threads suspended
in the
chamber of consciousness and catching
every airborne
particle in its tissue
that's james and in modern fiction
of 1919 virginia woolf says something
actually quite similar and i quote
the mind receives a myriad impressions
trivial fantastic evanescent or engraved
with the sharpness of steel from
all sides they come an incessant shower
of innumerable atoms
and as they fall as they shape
themselves into the life of monday or
tuesday the accent falls differently
from of old end of quote
a huge spider web of the finest silken
threads
suspended in the chamber of
consciousness
rights james the image is as striking
as its implications are remarkable
there seems to be a passive quality
to experience here suspended
the net sways in our consciousness
almost forgotten
and the cobweb itself immediately
conjures up
images of neglect and abandonment
airborne particles which i suppose
stand here for external stimuli simply
land on it there is no act of reaching
out
something similar happens in wolf's
passage
i quote again the mind receives
a myriad impressions she writes from all
sides they come
an incessant shower of innumerable atoms
just like james with his web wolf says
we are hit
with different intensities by events
and impressions some of which engrave
themselves on the mind there is no
active collection
nor is there a selection or sifting
through these particles or atoms
they simply fall and shape themselves
without
our intervention into what we perceive
to be
our lives no two the microscopic
scale of the metaphor which gives it a
scientific
objective slant experience they both
seem to be saying
is highly granular detailed down
to the atomic level and this is why
it is never limited and it is never
complete now given this
how should fiction approach experience
again james and wolf provide similar
answers
let's go first with james and i quote
catching the very note and trick the
strange irregular rhythm of
life that is the attempt whose strenuous
force
keeps fiction upon her feet
in proportion as in what she offers us
we see life
without rearrangement do we feel that we
are touching
the truth in proportion as we see it
with rearrangement do we feel that we
are being put off
with a substitute a compromise
and convention that was henry james
now virginia woolf she writes
life is not a series of gig lamps
symmetrically arranged
life is a luminous halo a
semi-transparent envelope surrounding us
from the beginning of consciousness
to the end is it not the task of the
novelist
to convey this varying this unknown
and uncircumscribed spirit whatever
aberration
or complexity it may display with as
little mixture of the alien and external
as possible end of quote
so life is limitless
complex and uncircumscribed
it is inapprehensible in its every
infinitesimal detail
life is not symmetrically arranged but
has
a strange irregular rhythm it doesn't
conform to pre-established norms
but reinvents itself constantly
according to how the dust
the particles the atoms settles
the task of fiction then is to mimic
experience and present whatever has been
caught
in its web without rearrangement
james even uses italics without
rearrangement
and with as little mixture of the alien
and external as possible
wolf just as experience
does not select its stimuli but merely
receives them
so the writer should not tamper with
experience
reorganizing it or tidying it up
sure i think
any random page by wolf or james
will disprove their own precepts
who could seriously believe that these
two wonderful
control freaks of all writers
did not rearrange or mix the alien and
external into what they wrote
with a certain idea of order in mind
i would even claim that the more they
strive
to capture the strange irregular rhythm
of life
the more they focus on the
semi-transparent
envelope surrounding us the more
controlled
arranged and formally aware they prose
become becomes
honoring the opacity of life demands
great clear sightedness rendering
its chaotic complexity requires
an equally complex sense of order
if their prose were insufficient
evidence
the most cursory glands at wolves diary
or james's prefaces
would confirm this
we are not perceiving machines
our eyes are not cameras our ears
are not recording devices
there is nothing automatic or passive
about perception and unless we become
like emerson a transparent
eyeball that can see all because it's
part or particle of god
we need to accept that perception
is rearrangement and that multiple
processes of selection
and readjustment are at play as
we experience the world
far from dismissing or concealing them
literature captures and even reveals
these processes it is precisely
because it rearranges and intervenes
from
outside that fiction imitates the way we
perceive
life which is always through some sort
of
substitute compromise and convention
and these three terms which james
dreaded so much
define not only literary forms and
genres
but also language itself
substitute compromise convention
section four
the title is the field the window
the watcher in 1908
almost 25 years after the publication of
the art
of fiction james wrote the preface to
the new york edition
of the portrait of a lady here
the chamber of consciousness has
expanded to become the famous
house of fiction from which the writer
gets a necessarily
partial view of life
gone from this house are the cobwebs
hanging
in his earlier essay no longer a passive
figure
the writer now needs to pierce holes in
the wall
in order to get a view of the world
beyond
there are i quote a million possible
windows that could open up to
an incalculability of range says james
the particular aperture the writer
creates will determine which portion
of that unlimited experience can be
perceived and narrated
and i quote again from james
the spreading field the human scene
is the choice of subject the pierced
aperture
either broad or balconied or slit-like
and
low-brow is the literary form
but they are singly or together as
nothing without the posted presence of
the watcher
without in other words the consciousness
of the artist that was henry james
there is then after all a need to
rearrange and frame the strange
irregular rhythm of life
form is what comes between the thing
watched
and the watcher conditioning what we can
see
and how we see it expanding james's
simile let's say
there are three types of stories
those that focus on the spreading field
outside the house of fiction
those that are concerned with the design
of the window framing
that view and those that focus
on the watcher or the consciousness of
the artist
of course this is schematic the
categories
overlap and good fiction usually has
element of all three but perhaps you'll
bear with me and indulge me
an emblematic uh novel in the first
group
is the life and strange surprising
adventures of
robinson crusoe of fjork mariner written
by himself of course the last part of
the title
written by himself already tells us
where this is going
and the preface penned by an editor
confirms it and i quote from this
preface it says
the editor believes the thing to be just
history of fact
neither is there any appearance of
fiction
in it end of quote so
whether it succeeds or not the novel
stakes its claim on its truthfulness
and denies its fictional quality this is
not fiction
narratives like this compel us through a
variety of rhetorical means
to forget they are effective they
present us with the world
and ask us to pretend that we take it
for the real thing this group
includes i think most modern western
fiction
it was consolidated during the rise of
realism in the 19th century
and still holds sway today
all those life-like stories that
regardless of genre or how
fanciful their setting may be rely on
readers
suspension of disbelief on their
accepting for a
moment that they're being presented with
the actual
even speculative novels like le guins
may fall
under this category by the way so
this is fiction that wishes we could
forget
that we're looking through a framed pane
of glass and believe rather that we are
on the spreading field
the second group literature that shows
an overt
concern for the window has a strange
history
consider the author's apology for this
book that precedes
the pilgrim's progress where john bunyan
openly announces that the following
pages
are a fable mere fancies
fancies which rather than imitating life
are in the similitude of a dream
or thackeray's preface to vanity fair
titled
before the curtain in which the author
introduces himself
as the manager of the performance on the
stage
they're not even actors but puppets
dolls and figures these are
three words from the preface the
manager's last gesture
in the preface is to bow to his patrons
and
rise the curtain to reveal the stage
this curtain is the same one that james
draws to look out his window the window
that stands let's remember for literal
reform
this brings me to the strange evolution
of fiction
in this category i believe the
apologetic drive which can be
one with the impulse to reduce fiction
to a mere allegory or a fable
that never asks to be taken at face
value
became the self-preferential gesture
that defines
so much of what we may hastily call
experimental fiction i place
in this group all stories that draw
attention to the fact that they are
verbal fabrications narratives
that rather than trying to pass
for the truth announce in different ways
their fictional status and reflect on
their formal
configuration this includes all event
guard literature that works on the
premise of
alienation estrangement or distancing
showing and drawing attention to the
artifice
of it all closer to our present time
what is known as metafiction and other
self-conscious narratives
may fall under this category as well in
short
all those novel that as elizabeth
elizabeth hardwick
put it in reflection on fiction show
a degree of panic about the form
and finally we have the fiction focused
on the posted presence of the watcher
or in other words the consciousness
of the artist with a slight of
hand in other words is what
james slips in there james conflates
two different very different worlds on
the one hand
the watcher is posted in
the house of fiction looking out the
window
which makes the watcher a textual being
just like the characters on the lawn
on the other the consciousness of the
artist
refers to someone from an altogether
different plane
someone this side of the book
like the readers it is safe
i think to equate the watcher
with the narrator while the
consciousness of the artist
is closer to the author without of
course fully overlapping
with this extra-literary presence
nothing in fiction neither the scene nor
the frame
exists without this perceiving
watcher says james but this is a hybrid
undecisive ever mutating being
it's alternatively and often
simultaneously
inside and outside the text
its view is limited by point of view
which is very much an internal
construction of the story but it's also
informed by the consciousness
of the writer which isn't quite a
literary
occurrence this presence inhabits
a liminal zone it can jump out the
window
and join the party out on the lawn as do
all first-person narrators but
it can also turn its back to the window
and face us
i have always been drawn to stories that
revolve
around this presence because they often
try to complicate
inherited notions of what literature may
be
and they do so through the process of
unfolding themselves as
literature the classic example would be
the nesting dolls in don quixote
in which the distinctions among author
narrator
character and reader are in crisis
which means the distinction between the
inside and the outside
of the house of fiction is also unclear
here are some of my favorite texts
that question these boundaries machado
diazis does it in the posthumous memoirs
of braz kubas
in which his dead character is also the
narrator who promises to reach out of
the book and
flick his reader in the head if he
doesn't like it
robert walcer does it in the robber with
his authorial interventions
macedonio fernandez does it in museum of
eterna's novel
a novel made up of four words to that
novel
jorge luis borges does it in several
stories by
directly addressing and involving the
reader in the plot
by silently quoting himself and by
making
several hitchcock-like cameos
claricely spectre does it in the hour of
the star
in which the narrator is a character
writing the story we're reading
muriel spark does it in the comforters
her first novel
in which the protagonist literally hears
the author
type her thoughts as she is thinking
them and we are reading them
samuel beckett
does it through the prenomial shifts in
company
david markson does it masterfully over
and over again
in his last four novels where he appears
pitched
against the entire western canon under
the name of reader
protagonist novelist or author
these texts fold upon themselves
and in a mobius like contortion
become their own referential reality
gertrude stein could not have put it
more clearly the more a novel is
and i quote excuse me the more a novel
is a novel
the more a play is a play the more a
writing
is a writing the more no outside is
outside
outside is inside inside is inside
end of quote i
distrust taxonomies and grids of any
sort
applied to literature but with this
hesitating and i'm sure questionable
classification
i hope to show how fiction can have
different dispositions
toward truth fiction concerned with the
spreading field
is true because it mimics certain
unquestioning ways
in which we experience reality
fiction concerned with the pierced
aperture
is true because it's honest about its
own artificial status and it makes us
consider the extent to which reality
may also be a framed narrative
and fiction concerned with the watcher
is true because it understands the
ambiguity
and instability of all the terms
involved here mainly reality
fiction and frame in the end
these are all ways of experiencing our
relationship
to the world which at times can be
immediate
and wholly immersive at times
painfully and self-consciously
distant
five and last the emotion
itself
in october 1926
the yale review published an essay
by virginia woolf titled how should one
read a book
which is a wonderful essay that we
should all read
uh a few pages into her piece
she explains the fiction writer's work
and i'll quote here a little bit at
length but it's a beautiful text
wolf writes perhaps the quickest way to
understand the elements
of what a novelist is doing is not to
read
but to write to make your own experiment
with
the dangers and difficulties of words
recall then some event that has left a
distinct impression on you
how at the corner of the street perhaps
you passed two people talking a tree
shook
an electric light danced the tone of the
talk was comic
but also tragic a whole vision an entire
conception
seemed contained in that moment
but when you attempt to reconstruct it
in words
you will find that it breaks into a
thousand conflicting
impressions some must be subdued
others emphasized in the process
you will lose probably all grasp upon
the emotion
itself then turn from your blurred and
littered pages
to the opening pages of some great
novelist
defoe jane austen hardy
now you will be better able to
appreciate
their mastery that's the end of
wolf if james's view
of the novelist's task changed over time
so did wolves during the seven years
that separate
modern fiction the first text i quoted
from this text here like there
impressions are the point of departure
here like there we are confronted with
the multifaceted
and uncontainable nature of experience
and by the way note the unstable light
illuminating both passages a
semi-transparent halo in the first one
a flickering bulb here as if to show us
there is something opaque
and wavering about perception
but instead of the almost mystical
passivity
that wolf encouraged in modern fiction
in this essay
she acknowledges the need to subdue some
impressions
while emphasizing others blurriness
unless deliberately crafted is not
a desired outcome without some sort of
order the myriad impressions that fall
on the mind
are mere litter on the page crucially
though
form should be at the service of keeping
one's
grasp upon the emotion itself and this
brings me to my final thoughts
to recapitulate fiction that pack of
lies
is in pursuit of its own form of truth
i know this truth has little to do with
accurately describing referential
reality i suspect
it may be related to the attempt at
presenting the many ways
in which we experience the world i
believe
this attempt to be mediated by form the
individual
choices and inherited configurations by
which we rearrange our perceptions
i also think that literature's
disposition toward form
the ways in which it conceals reveals
and reflects on its artificial nature
defines
its distinctive relationship to truth
but this definition seems insufficient
it reduces fiction to more or less
self-aware reports on non-existent
worlds these reports may mimic
with different degrees of success the
ways in which we relate to the actual
world
still fiction does more than this
it not only mimics experience
it is itself an experience
let's return to wolf she notes that a
hypothetical writer trying to capture
experience
will likely lose all grasp upon the
emotion itself
grasping and emotion this seems to be
fiction's main purpose
the emotion is what needs to be conjured
up and preserved
in the text it is this to which
all other elements including form are
subordinated
because form as george eliot noted in an
1868 essay is quote not only determined
by emotion
but intended to express it end of quote
i ought to underscore at once that i am
not most emphatically not speaking here
about the many vicarious sentiments
a story may seek to excite in us as we
read
it's not about feeling captain ahab's
wrath
emma bovary's desire or hans kostorp's
malaise
as if these emotions were our own
i'm referring rather to the general
feeling that fiction when successful
stirs in us regardless of specific
content
in his lecture on dickens nabokov says
and i quote
although we read with our minds the seat
of artistic delight is between the
shoulder blades
that little shiver behind is quite
certainly the highest form of
emotion that humanity has attained
when evolving pure art and pure science
end of quote must confess i've never
felt
uh that shivered down my spine to me
it's more
like a body-wide fizz but
the point still stands um
and i agree artistic delight is one of
the highest
forms of emotion we can experience
and this i think is the emotion wolf
is referring to and without it fiction
however formally sophisticated becomes
simply a pack of lies in that
same essay george eliot asks what is
fiction and i quote sorry
what is fiction other than an
arrangement of events
or feigned correspondences according to
a predominant
feeling end of quote
there is so much to love about this
pithy definition of fiction
the main one for me is the marriage
between
form and feeling which again i take to
be
an aesthetic emotion one that is free
from any sort of correspondence with a
referential
world for it has nothing to do with
imitating
any passions in our emotional palate a
rush of courage
or a pang of guilt we may recognize in
this
or that character feeling of artistic
delight
is conjured up by the text itself
and is not anchored to anything external
furthermore it cannot be found outside
the text
it is a literary event
exclusively because this particular
experience has one defining quality
since literature's prime material is
language
it follows that this aesthetic emotion
will be not only a sensory event as the
delight we can find in pure
color or in pure sound but also
a semantic one
fiction is not a collection of falsehood
or irrelevant fabrications it is
rather a certain kind of narrative
that shows us the many ways in which we
experience
life whether it wishes to accurately
address referential reality
or not and it does so
while adding an experience to that
life what happens to us
this feeling of plenitude when we read
fiction
takes place at the intersection of
meaning
and emotion and it is always mediated
by form the physical enjoyment of
language in its visual and oral
dimensions
the wonder of seeing something come into
being
as it takes shape in a sentence
the many evocations a word or paragraph
may conjure
up the miracle of time
expanding and contracting on the page
the love a certain verbal creature may
inspire
these are some of the ways in which we
experience
this intensity which shifts fiction
away from the imperative of
correspondence with the empirical
world and it is this emotion
that brings friction closer to truth
while freeing it from its referential
anxiety
showing us how much beauty there can be
in meaning thank you so much
um thank you so much hernan that was
really
wonderful and so many ideas to think
about and unpack here and
sadly i know we won't get to talk about
all of them
um i want to remind our audience that
they can
ask questions in the q a um even if we
don't get to talk about all our
questions today
i hope that you'll be able to read the
piece in the review and that will be
another way to engage with this but
i thought i would start us off and then
turn to the audience um
i'm not sure where i want to start
because there's so many things i wanted
to ask you about but i think i'd like to
start
by returning to what you just talked
about about this feeling of plenitude
when we read fiction deriving from as
you put at the intersection of meaning
and emotion and always mediated by
form and i wonder if we could pivot to
talk a little bit about
writing fiction um and how that sense of
plenitude comes into writing and how you
free yourself
from this um
referential adherence that you talked
about
um and that might take us back to the
very beginning of the
talk where you talked about the
difference between reading
and research um and perhaps you could
unpack
this a little bit more from the writer's
point of view
um well thank you and i'm sorry i see
that i took a little longer than
anticipated so i apologize for that um
um uh how to escape the referential
anxiety during the process of
writing i think i think the answer is uh
contained uh someplace within within
this this talk i would i would like to
say nothing is as tidy and you're a
writer so you know this
nothing is as tidy as it comes off in in
this presentation
everything is uh much more it's it's a
mess
it's whimsical it's it's it's it's not a
controlled environment
uh at least for me uh uh maybe some
people are more
you know methodic but um
but i would say uh that uh
for me it's always putting at the center
uh
the emotional aspect of of of writing
and i think
that's the beautiful thing about fiction
that it's a highly intellectual endeavor
but at the same time it has it has to be
emotionally stirring
uh that's true for all literature and
not not just
fiction it applies obviously to poetry
as well for instance
um so that's sort of my
inner uh uh whatever device
calibrating device if i'm if i'm leaning
toward one side or the other
um i feel that uh you know if if you
become too
focused on the intellectual side on the
formal side
uh uh you run the risk of just
building a a very beautiful but cold
cathedral that is completely uninhabited
but on the other hand if you if you
overplay the emotional side i mean
no nobody nobody's interested in in like
feelings right that's that's unmediated
feelings are a little
yucky so yeah
or at least as i tell my students you
know you could have the biggest feelings
in the world and sadly they do not
translate to the
the biggest success right
you talked in some interviews i read
about this distinction between
um reading and research and i thought it
was so astute you know i i
i remember having a moment writing a
poem where i had done a lot of research
into 19th century books
where i had kind of put in some detail
about pigskin vellum and i thought no no
the speaker of this poem would not be
thinking about her book this way it
would just be
right so so part of what you seem to get
at in this distinction between reading
and research that i think
applies back to what you're talking
about here
is the idea that it's not verisimilitude
necessarily that you're looking for it's
it's this more complex dimensional
um world building i guess sort of
combination of world and affect building
and it but i wonder what that actually
looks like you know in the distance is
is set in a time that is not our time so
how do you
distinguish you know you are in a sense
doing research right but
clearly there's a distinction for you
how do you
how do you put that into practice well
it's
it is it is there is a distinction for
me and i hope i'm not doing research as
as defined
uh a moment ago uh i
i have to say also you know i i i was
trained as an academic so i do have
like a lot of experience with archival
work and library work i'm actually at
the new york public library now where
i'm where i'm
not doing research and
uh um uh
so on the one hand that gives me
some sense of discipline which i which i
think is really important like
sticking with it even if it's like
inhabiting boredom
i think it's a very important part of
being a writer
uh i think it's crucial
but you know it's not research in the
traditional sense
because i am i am not out to corroborate
some contextual facts or or trying to
make my prose more accurate
to give you like very quick examples the
the kind of stuff that i'm looking for
is very weird
i'm looking uh for instance for a
little little um how can i put it
little verbal props you know for example
in the case of the 19th century
uh that i think will do a lot more work
than really figuring out what happened
truly blow by blow at the whatever
mountain meadows massacre which is
important to know
but i think if you if you find that that
little word
um that will that will uh almost uh
alchemically conjure up a
whole a whole universe that is worth
more than than all the fact checking in
the world
and i get to those words by just
reading a lot while i'm writing i know a
lot of writer friends don't
even read fiction as they write the
wrong fiction i'm
the opposite uh like i read all of
dickens while writing in the distance
and that
somehow gave a sense of 19th century
language that that you can only get that
way just by being immersed in that world
and i don't think that's necessarily
research
no i love this distinction it's very
useful to me personally um
i'm going to ask one question from the
audience and then that's probably all we
have time for but
sorry um a member um no we wanted to
hear your wonderful talk um we had a
member of the audience ask
what advice do you have for authors who
are setting stories
even partially outside their own
cultural experience
in nations they don't know or among
people whose identity is the author
doesn't
hold her well yeah that's a really
complicated question
i think uh and it's something that i
that i deal with
uh myself i don't i don't i don't find
that i write
necessarily about myself and my
environment
i think the i think the first question
is why do you need to tell this story
i think i think that's the question that
uh you need to ask yourself
and and be dead honest with yourself
about it why
do you need to uh go into this world
when it when it it's not
given to you uh and i think the the
second element is
is never to be a tourist in in in
in that world you know uh and and to
really uh uh uh try to try to understand
it and if if you understand
why you need to go there chances are
that
maybe you will also understand uh uh uh
why you were drawn to it in the first
place but i think
it's a longer answer of course and and i
understand it has
a lot of political connotations but i
think we should all be brave enough
to venture outside our world and
and write about others because otherwise
you know literature
will be reduced to a selfie in a way
i love that distinction of the tourists
i do want to get to one more question if
you're patient enough
um hernan to do one more but of course
calabrese who is here
did ask a question i'd love to hear the
answer to and he said
as you were talking i kept thinking
about my reaction at seeing a work of
visual art and how similar that was
do you feel there is a is there a
difference excuse me can you repeat that
if
there's a oh it's here okay uh
oh yes no absolutely i think i think
it's
uh uh and and and thank you judge
calabrese for being here by the way it's
a it's it's a great honor i didn't know
you you were in the audience
and for making this this series possible
uh
definitely i think it's very important
uh to have
almost like a synesthetic approach to
literature
i think uh visual vividness is
all important but i'm also very
interested in
uh the auditive dimension uh of of of
prose and
and and how evocative sounds may be i
think literature gives us this
opportunity of and
and you megan as a poet you know
know all about this but just the way a a
word
looks and sounds and how it interacts
with its meaning is just such a
beautiful thing to
to use to one's advantage well this has
been
really wonderful thank you so much thank
you all for coming today
i know we're sad not to be in a physical
space together but we're really glad to
be in this virtual space together
delighted again to tell you the talk
will be published in the summer
issue of the yale review you can
subscribe at our website or pre-order
the issue if you're interested
and thank you again to alice kaplan and
the whitney humanities center for
hosting this event and having us all
here
thank you everyone have a wonderful day
thank you megan thank you everyone